Okay, so welcome back. We're going to
continue now building out the trade idea
generation process. Welcome to video
number 23, quantitative processing number
two. What we're going to be doing in this
video is start showing you some processes
of how to start filtering for price
earnings ratio.
and also add in some additional measures
in the quant processing phase. So, in the
previous video, we use the price earnings
ratio as an identification process for
finding both positive and negative
outliers in a sector. Now, in building a
long short portfolio, we want to first
always identify
what money likes and what money dislikes.
We mentioned in the previous video that
money likes growth. Now, when we identify
outliers by price earnings ratio, we do it
by ranking the PE largest to smallest. And
there will always be a reason behind why a
stock has a high PE or why a stock has a
low PE or even
or even an average middle of the road, an
exciting PE in a sector. It's up to us
after identifying an outlier to do more
work on it and figure it out. So, because
we know that money likes growth, it's
highly likely that the reason for a high
PE valuation, i.e. that investors and
traders are willing to pay the premium,
it's because, in some way, it's because,
in some way, the stock has superior growth
to its sector counterparts. And likewise,
on the flip side, it's highly likely that
with low PE stocks relative to sector
peers, investors and traders are willing
to sell at the discount because, in some
way, the stock has inferior growth to its
sector counterparts.
Now, the main measures of growth that we
use as traders and portfolio managers in
the quantitative phase are forward-looking
earnings growth, forward revenue growth,
forward PE ratio, and forward PE ratio.
And the PE ratio is simply the PE ratio
divided by the earnings growth percentage.
So, try to remember this every time you
look at a table of data for a sector where
you see price earnings ratio, earnings
growth percentage, and PEG ratio, and
revenue growth.
Try to remember this, there is always a
reason why a stock trades on a premium or
a discount to its sector peers for all of
those metrics. Say it in your mind every
time you look at the table of data. Remind
yourself, ask yourself the question, what
is the reason? There is always a reason.
What is the reason?
And what you're going to find is that in
the vast majority of cases, it is because
the stock has superior earnings growth or
inferior earnings growth. That is usually
the case in the vast majority of
situations at any one time in financial
markets. Now, of course, there will be
exceptions, but we have to focus on the
majority.
We have to focus on the majority scenario
for now. So, for this video, you're
actually going to need access to the
downloadable spreadsheet that's under the
video in the downloads area called the US
Sector Data. Now, this spreadsheet is very
important for you. It's a spreadsheet
that's going to be very helpful for your
ongoing processes for trade idea
generation.
So, the spreadsheet is updated twice a
year. The spreadsheet is updated twice a
year in the PTM download section and it's
updated every month in the ITPM data
library. And of course, you can get the
data yourself online for free. Just go to
video 25 and you will see Chris Quill's
tutorial video on how to do that.
Now, what we've done is we've downloaded a
sector from the spreadsheet file. And the
sector that we've downloaded here is the
non-store retail sector, which is part of
the larger sector retail trade.
And this is the non-store retail industry.
And this is a NAICS classification of
sectors. So, this is the North American
industry classification system, which is
obviously different from the global
industry classification sectors. The GICS
definition of sectors.
One is global and one is global and one is
from North America only. It doesn't really
matter which definitions you use. Whatever
you're comfortable with and wherever you
can get a large amount of usable and
accurate data.
And you go and get it and you use it for
your processes. The NAICS sector
definition is very straightforward and
it's very easy to get the free data and
filter through the data with your
processes.
Also, the NAICS sector classification is
used by the Institute of supply
management. So, if you're generating trade
ideas that are originating from ISM
reports, this classification would
actually be a natural extension for that.
So, what have we got on the screen here?
We're focusing on the non-store retail
sector for our example. And what you're
looking at are consensus numbers that are
pulled from NASDAQ.com, then sorted by
ITPM on a monthly basis.
Now, obviously, you can do this yourself.
You can go to NASDAQ.com, you can download
the data and sort this spreadsheet
yourself any way you want to do it.
Now, the way we happen to like sorting the
data is to have it so it's visualized with
our most important metrics for our
filtering process, visualized all in one
place.
So, very easy to scan with your eye and
organize all of the data easily when
you're playing around with the
spreadsheets. So, what do we have here? If
you look at the data, first of all, we
have the dates where the company's
year-end is cut off.
So, for example, if you look in the
column, you'll see many of the companies,
their year-end ends at the end of
December, at the end of the calendar year.
So, their financial year is at the end of
the calendar year.
Then we have market cap. Market cap, we
have on the screen there. And next to it,
you can see that we have EPS. So, we have
four columns here for EPS. We have EPS
full year zero, EPS full year one, EPS
full year two, and EPS full year three.
So, what is that?
Well, by definition, zero by our
definition is last year's EPS. Then we
have EPS full year one. So, EPS FY one.
What is that? Well, it is one year forward
EPS. So, it's the current year. So, let's
say you're sitting in February or March or
June. EPS full year one.
EPS full year one is the forward looking
one year EPS for that year. Okay? Then EPS
full year two. EPS FY two is the next
year. So, it's not this year that we're
currently in. It's the year after. And
then EPS full year three is the year after
that.
Now, EG stands for earnings growth. So, we
have earnings growth F1. So, earnings
growth F1 is for the current year. So,
that is the same year as EPS full year
one.
Again, earnings growth F2, that is the
same year as EPS full year two. So, if you
look at EG F1, for example, that is the
earnings growth that the company is
experiencing in the current year based on
the forward forecast.
So, based on the forward forecast. So,
based on the forward forecast, it's the
percentage change from last year's
reported EPS, which is in year zero, and
the current year.
Earnings growth F2 is the forecasted EPS
of next year versus the forecasted EPS of
the current year. And it's the percentage
difference between the two. So, it's a
forecast of earnings growth from the
estimated consensus EPS numbers for the
current year to the following year.
And then we have earnings growth in year
three. And that's the earnings growth from
year two to year three. So, EPS growth
based on forecasts by the market, by
research analysts, the growth, the
earnings growth from year two to year
three.
Now, the next columns, we have the PE
ratio. And what we're doing is here is we
take current stock price in the market.
And we use EPS forward for full year one.
So, that is a forward PE for the current
year. So, year one. And then we have next
year. So, we have the PE for next year.
And then we have next year. So, we have
the PE for next year.
So, current stock price divided by the EPS
of year two. And then, of course, the same
thing for year three, the current stock
price divided by the EPS estimate for year
three.
And then, finally, we have the PEG ratios.
The PEG ratios for full year one, two, and
three in the final three columns. Now, at
this stage, don't worry about all of the
data in the table. Just try to focus on
the simple stuff for now and not go down
endless rabbit holes. Focus on the simple
stuff for now.
And the process itself. So, we're focusing
on the non-store retail sector. Our first
step in the quantitative process when
attempting to identify sector outliers, as
we outlined in the previous video, is to
filter the spreadsheet for forward PE one.
So, if you look on the screen, you'll see
the spreadsheet.
that the spreadsheet has been filtered in
descending order from the highest PE for
year one to the lowest PE. And when we do
this, certain stocks are obviously going
to jump off the screen as positive and
negative outliers based on the metric for
PE in year one.
And here, in our example, we've decided to
highlight three stocks. We've decided to
highlight Shopify, Wayfair, and Overstock.
You can see on the screen there that
Shopify has a PE full year one. So,
forward looking PE for the current year of
287.
Wayfair comes in at overstock comes in at
overstock comes in at overstock comes in
at 67 times earnings for the current year.
Now, the next step we tend to take is to
start looking at earnings growth because
we want to understand what is driving the
valuation.
So, the first thing we look at, because it
happens in the vast majority of cases at
any one moment in time, the next thing we
look at is earnings.
First, we want to see the earnings growth
of the company to see if the earnings
growth measures are supporting the
valuation.
So, the next thing we do is filter by the
one year forward earnings growth.
So, e.g. what? So, what's that? It's the
difference, the percentage difference
between last year's EPS and this year's
EPS, which is a forward looking estimate.
So, the percentage difference. So, when we
look at the screen here, we did highlight
the stocks in the table.
So, when we re-sorted the data by EG1,
SHOP has projected flat earnings growth
year on year, overstock has pretty flat
projected earnings growth year on year,
and Wayfair earnings growth is actually
projected to half.
So, this begs the obvious question, why
are these stocks trading on such a high
premium relative to other stocks in the
sector?
Remember, these are live stock prices in
the market every day, and there's people
paying those prices every day live in the
market.
And we've taken that stock price, and
we've used it to work out PE ratio.
So, the market is rating these stocks for
a reason.
So, it obviously begs the question, why
are they trading on such a high premium
relative to the other stocks in the
sector?
Well, this is just an initial inquiry.
It may actually be because of other
reasons.
So, we don't just give up.
We ask the obvious question, why?
And we keep asking the question.
So, what do we do next?
Well, we filter for EG2.
So, we filter for next year's forward
earnings growth.
And we discover that both Wayfair and
Overstock have much higher than average
earnings growth for next year.
And SHOP has pretty non-spectacular
earnings growth.
So, the high PEs for both Wayfair and
Overstock seem to be because the market is
looking through the current year and
paying the premium now for next year's
earnings growth and potentially beyond
next year.
So, why is it the case that earnings
growth for SHOP, Wayfair and Overstock is
bad in the current year?
Again, it's up to you to keep asking the
obvious questions and find out.
Well, I can tell you now, the year for
EPS1, which is feeding all of our other
formulas, was 2020.
So, it was the COVID year.
Now, another question you might ask
yourself in a situation like this is, for
example,
why Shopify is trading on such a massive
current year forward PE premium to the
rest of the sector when it only has flat
earnings growth in year one versus year
zero and 25% forecast for year two growing
from year one.
Well, remember, there is always a reason.
So, it's up to you to find out that
reason.
A typical question you might ask yourself
here, which would be fairly obvious to ask
yourself, is maybe it's not to do with
earnings.
Maybe it's to do with something else.
Maybe it's to do with another very
important metric, revenue.
So, it might be to do with revenue growth.
So, the company is possibly purposely
reinvesting a large portion of their
earnings back into the business in order
to grow the top line.
Maybe that's the case.
At this stage, we don't know.
We're just continuing our lines of inquiry
and asking the obvious questions.
So, in this situation, if that is the
case, then the market will actually see
through this.
And the premium is for way in the future
earnings.
So, it's more of a revenue growth story.
And if they are communicating this to the
market, it will all be part of what we
call the MOP, the Management Operating
Plan.
At this stage, we just don't know.
We are in the discovery phase of the quant
process.
And we are asking the obvious questions to
find out the basics of the picture or
story of the sector.
And trying to identify interesting
positive outliers.
And indeed, interesting negative outliers.
What we also see here is that Shopify has
by far the largest market capitalization
of the three companies.
So, this is also worth noting too.
Now, just as a side note, the data in the
tables that we've looked at so far hasn't
been fully cleaned.
Later in the video series, we're going to
show you how to clean data like in the
tables that we've been looking at.
We're going to show you how to clean that
data properly.
All this is at this stage is an example of
process.
It's a template of how you go about doing
things on a step-by-step basis.
Now, you may be wondering at this stage,
when you look at the tables there, you may
be wondering why we haven't looked at
other stocks like Amazon or Alibaba.
Well, in long short portfolio management,
market capitalization matters.
If you've seen the IPLT video series and
Chris Quill's lessons in volatility, you
will totally understand what I'm getting
at here.
We will discuss other reasons why in more
detail later in the video series.
So as we're going through our process,
normally we would eliminate Shopify as a
potential long trade idea due to its
market cap size.
But that doesn't stop us actually
including it in our analysis.
So we understand Wayfair and Overstock
better in a better context.
So basically what we have as our three
choices here in our example is a very
large market cap size in Shopify from the
table.
We have a small market cap size over stock
from the table and Wayfair what we would
define as a media or average size market
cap in the table.
Now a useful exercise when you're going
through this process is to sometimes just
get the rankings from the sector in a
little Excel table.
So we have 17 stocks in the sector and
we've ranked the stocks here on market cap
PE.
So this is the PE 1, earnings growth 1 and
earnings growth 2.
So we rank them by those metrics just to
get a clear picture of the most important
comparable fundamentals and where they
rank relative to each other within the
sector.
Now we know that for W and Overstock, the
market is actually looking ahead to
earnings growth 2 and paying the premium
now.
So in the rankings here, W is ranked as
number 2 based on earnings growth 2 out of
the 17 stocks and Overstock is ranked as 3
for earnings growth 2 relative to the 17
stocks.
Now, given that normally we would not even
consider Shopify as a potential long trade
idea because of the market cap size and
because we're traders.
This is something we will come on to later
in the video series.
We consider W and Overstock and based on
the market cap size of those two stocks
and the earnings growth 2 profiles of the
two stocks.
We conclude that Overstock probably has
the most potential and is probably the
most interesting positive outlier to do
further work on.
So we have gone through a very quick
filtering process to determine what money
likes and why it likes it at the surface
level quant phase.
We can be pretty confident why the market
pays the premium in Overstock.
It's for the earnings growth next year.
Additionally, it has a $3 billion market
cap.
So that gives us as traders plenty of room
for upside potential over our time horizon
of 20 to 60 days.
And then we now continue our investigation
to fill in all the gaps.
So the next step would be to start looking
at some of the basic quantitative numbers
of the profit and loss account.
So here we have Shopify and we have their
main headline profit and loss account
numbers from 2012 all the way up to 2020,
which is the last reported number.
And we also have forecasts for 2021 and
2022.
So we start taking a note of the last
reported numbers, the last annual numbers,
and we start to work things out.
So if we look at the column 2020, we can
see revenue came in at 2,929,000,000 and
there was revenue growth of 85%.
Other lines to take note of would be cost
of revenue, which comes in at 1.387
billion, our gross profit of 1.54 billion
and also our operating expenses of 1.4
billion.
Within operating expenses, we have to take
note of R&D, so research and development
costs.
We also look at our operating income or
loss, which is 133 million.
We look at our pre-tax income or loss, 148
million.
And that's on an adjusted basis and on a
gap basis, 240 million.
We also take note of the forward looking
projections from the market.
So research analysts in the market, and we
note revenue of just over 4 billion with
37 and a half percent revenue growth.
We have a forecast for gross profit at 2.1
billion, an operating income of just over
400 million, and a pre-tax income or loss
on an adjusted basis, 481 million.
Now it goes without saying, all of these
numbers are publicly available.
You can get them all via the investor
relations websites of any company for
free.
So we worked out revenue growth in 2020
for Shopify as 85%.
So 85% growth in revenue from 2019 to
2020.
The forward looking analyst consensus
revenue projection for Shopify was 37 and
a half percent for 2021 and 31 and a half
percent for 2022.
Revenue in 2021 was forecasted to be 4
billion.
And we note that the cost of revenue in
2020 was 1.3877 billion plus the operating
expenses of 1.4084 billion comes to a
total of 2.7961 billion in order to make
2.92 billion.
And their revenue was 2.9295 billion in
revenue.
So their total costs were 2.7961 billion.
And their revenue was 2.9295 billion.
Meaning that that is a 95% number.
So they are spending 95 cents to make $1
of revenue.
Now research and development spend is
typically an expense that software
companies enjoy while they are in their
growth phase.
So that when they're building out new
products and services and growing their
top line aggressively.
And it's usually worked out as a
percentage of revenue or operating cost, a
percentage of operating cost and or a
percentage of total cost.
And companies seek, as they're growing and
they're reaching maturity, companies seek
to pare this down as they grow to
maturity.
So as they grow to maturity, they're
paring down the percentage that R&D spend
contributes to revenue, operating costs
and also obviously total costs.
In the case of Shopify, R&D spend in 2020
made up $543.8 million.
And its percentage of total costs comes in
at 19.45%.
So we know that total costs for Shopify,
when we work it out on a per dollar basis,
that they're spending 95 cents to make
every dollar of revenue.
So we can multiply the 19.45% by the 95
cents to work out what R&D is as a
percentage of every dollar of revenue.
So it works out as 18.47 cents of the $1
of revenue that is spent on R&D.
What we can also do is work out R&D spend
on a per share basis.
So at the time of recording, Shopify had
112 million shares in issue.
So if we divide the $543 million of R&D
spend by the 112 million shares, we work
out that in 2020, Shopify, R&D spend,
R&D spend was $4.84 per share.
So we can make a very simple back of the
envelope assumption and calculation here
that if R&D spend at Shopify actually went
to zero, this $4.84 in 2020 could be added
back to potential pre-tax earnings.
Now we also noted the revenue growth in
2020, the 85% was very, very aggressive
and it was down to COVID-19.
And the revenue growth in 2021 and 2022 is
actually forecast to firstly keep growing
at a very rapid pace.
So at 37% and 31% so that's potentially a
bold projection, but it's also forecast as
lower growth than the pre-COVID levels.
So for example, in 2018, revenue growth
was 60% and in 2019, 47%.
So the 37% and 31% for 2021 and 2022 is a
lower growth rate on the revenue level
than previous times to COVID-19.
And this is quite typical of companies
that mature and grow into maturity.
Revenue growth slows down and we get lower
levels of revenue growth for much bigger
companies that have already matured.
Something we also take note of is the
bottom line.
And we can see from the bottom line that
they're growing from loss making to profit
in 2020.
So what's happening here is that in the
bigger picture, the companies got to a
high market cap and has gone through a
large amount of their growth phase.
And they've had insane revenue growth and
obviously the markets rewarded them for
that.
And their bottom line is going from loss
making to profit making.
So essentially, the company has gone
through a big growth phase, got a high
market cap, being rewarded by the market.
And now revenue growth is slowing down and
they're moving into profit from a loss
making position.
The company has essentially matured.
The company has arrived.
So our suspicions earlier when we were
doing our surface level quant work in the
downloadable table of data was that
Shopify may be a revenue growth story and
that the market was putting a big premium
on the stock because of revenue growth at
the company.
And that the management operating plan may
be that it's a revenue growth situation
and they're purposely growing revenue and
reinvesting a lot of that revenue and
earnings back into growing the top line.
Therefore, the market sees through the low
earnings.
What we've discovered now is that this is
probably the case.
But the question is, does the stock
justify its full premium at this moment in
time moving forward?
That's the that's a question that remains
to be answered.
Moving on to Wayfair.
Again, we do some work here on their
numbers.
We look at 2020 and we see 14.145 billion.
That's 55% revenue growth from 2019.
We see our cost of revenue at 10 billion.
We see our gross profit at 4.1 billion.
We see our operating expenses at 3.747
billion.
R&D spend is zero.
And there's been no R&D spend throughout
the history of the data.
We have operating income in 2020 coming in
at 364 million.
And we have pre-tax income adjusted at
209, 209 million.
On a gap basis, 205 million.
We also take note of market projections.
So research analyst consensus projections
for revenue 2021, 15.844 billion.
That's 12% of revenue growth on 2020.
For 2022, just over 19 billion.
So 20% revenue growth for 2022 on 2021.
We have a gross profit number for 2021 as
well, 4.365 billion.
And for 2022, 5.3 billion.
We have an operating income number at 400
million for 2021, 686 for 2022.
And we have a pre-tax income on an
adjusted basis, 248 for 2021 and 544 for
2022.
So breaking it down for Wayfair, revenue
growth was just under 55% in 2020.
And the forward-looking analyst consensus
for revenue projections were 12% in 2021,
which is the current year.
And 20% for next year.
The forecast for 2021 was 15.8444 billion.
And we note the cost of revenue and
operating expenses, basically 10 billion
plus 3.7 billion.
We're looking at 13.7809 billion to make
14.1452 billion in revenue, which means
they are spending in total 97.42 cents to
make every $1 of revenue.
And we also noted they didn't have any R&D
spend, not in 2020 or for the entire
history of the company as a public
company.
The jump in revenue growth in 2020 was
clearly down to COVID-19.
And the revenue growth in 2021 and 2022 is
forecast to firstly keep growing.
So again, potentially a bold projection
versus the pre-COVID levels of revenue
growth to be lower than those levels.
So this is starting to look like, at least
at the revenue level, like a Shopify
situation.
But they don't actually have any R&D
spent.
Similarly, at the bottom line, they're
going from a loss-making position prior to
2020 to making a small profit in 2020.
So that's similar to the Shopify
situation.
But they're forecasted to lose money in
2021, but making profit in 2022.
So if we look back to the table, we're
actually looking at the net income line
here at the very bottom.
So we're looking at the 185 million profit
coming from a loss-making position of
almost a billion dollars in 2019.
So 185 million net profits, net income in
2020.
A loss here of 101 million in 2021 and a
profit of 131 million in 2022.
So the market is potentially here
overlooking the 2021 earnings slump in the
current year.
So 2021 is the current year.
And they're paying a premium now for
revenue and earnings growth, potentially
in 2022.
So they're potentially here giving them
the benefit now of 2022 revenue and
earnings growth.
So we're starting to learn a lot about
these stocks and the sector already.
Now, something else that's very useful
from an educational perspective in terms
of the process that we're going through
here.
And if you recall, Wayfair actually had a
positive EPS number in our downloadable
table that we looked at earlier.
So for 2021 in our table, they had an EPS
number of $2.31 for 2021, which is our one
year forward EPS number.
And if you just recall here on the P&L
statement, the forecasts for 2021 from
research analysts in our previous table,
the P&L projections that we just looked
at, the net income number was negative.
So there's obviously a conflict here.
So this is what happens sometimes when we
are going through our processes and our
usual lines of inquiry, where we're
digging deeper to find out what's going
on.
Sometimes there's a conflict of numbers.
Now, we know that the trajectory matches
up with our table and the P&L projections,
because in 2020, in our table, we had
$5.04 reported EPS for the 2020 year.
We got our one year forward as EPS as
$2.31 for 2021.
So that's obviously EPS in our table going
down by quite a lot.
And then from 2021 to 2022, we get a big
jump up to $5.82 per share.
And this trajectory from 2020 to 2021 to
2022 in our table matches up with the P&L
numbers.
But the numbers themselves in 2021, the
number itself in 2021 doesn't match up
because we have a positive $2.31 EPS
number in our table, but a negative net
income number in our other table.
So from a process perspective, it's useful
to highlight this because in a normal
process scenario, this can happen quite a
lot.
Sometimes you will bump into conflicting
numbers.
What you have to do is keep digging and
try to get as close to the truth as you
possibly can.
Obviously, in a normal process situation,
you would do that and accuracy is pretty
paramount.
You would need to work out whether the
downloadable data from the spreadsheet
download is incorrect or the P&L data that
you're downloading is incorrect.
And figure out what the actual accurate
situation is.
What we're doing here is simply just going
through the processes step by step to show
you how the processes and the steps work.
You would obviously, at various points in
your process, need to be making sure that
the data is clean, like we mentioned
earlier.
And this is a part of the process that
we'll be showing you later on in the video
series.
Now, let's move on to Overstock.
Again, we take note of the numbers like we
did with Shopify and Wayfair.
Revenue for 2020 came in at just over 2.5
billion, so 2,549,8 million.
That was revenue growth of just under 75%
on 2019.
We take note of our cost of revenue
number, 1.97 billion.
We also take note of gross profit, 579
million.
We also take note of our operating
expenses.
We take note that there is research and
development costs coming in at 137
million.
Operating income comes in at 33.4 million.
Pre-tax income at 37 million.
We also take note of the 2021 numbers,
2.65 billion at the revenue line.
That's a growth of 4% from 2020.
We take note of gross profit at 594 and
operating income at 57.
Pre-tax income forecast of 59.
Now, getting this all down on paper and
written down and doing some
back-of-the-envelope calculations.
The Overstock revenue growth, 75% in 2020.
The forward-looking analyst consensus
revenue projections for Overstock in the
current year,
2021, 4%.
So just under 4% coming in at 3.96%.
And 15.62% for the following year, 2022.
And the 15.62% revenue growth forecast in
2022 is actually higher than in all
previous years to the COVID-19 year in
2020.
2021 revenue is forecasted to be $2.6508
billion.
And we note the cost of revenue and
operating expenses on that.
So cost of revenue, $1.970 billion and
operating expenses $546.1 million, making
total cost $2.516.1 billion to make
revenue of $2.549 billion, which means
they are spending $0.98 in total to make
$1 of revenue.
Now, Overstock's research and development
spend, their R&D spend, was $137 million
in 2020.
So we work that out as a percentage of the
total costs, and it comes in at 5.4%.
So 5.4% of our $0.98 of total spend in
2020 is $5.292.
So R&D spend is $5.292 of every $1 of
revenue in 2020.
At the time of recording, there's 41
million shares in issue for Overstock.
So if we take the $137 million R&D spend,
we can work out on a per share basis the
R&D spend.
So that comes in at $3.34 per share for
R&D spend, which essentially, if Overstock
paid down its R&D spend to zero, could be
$3.34 per share of potential extra pre-tax
earnings.
Now, what we can actually do, seeing as
though we've now been through all three of
the companies and done a slightly deeper
dive on the quant,
what we can do is compare Shopify and
Overstock, and we can compare their R&D
spend per share and their EPS.
So if we remember, Shopify had $4.84 per
share R&D spend in 2020.
And we just looked at Overstock, that was
$3.34 per share for R&D spend in 2020.
If we recall from our table, that Shopify
had $3.98 of earnings per share in 2020.
And Overstock had $1.24 of earnings per
share in 2020.
So what we can do here is work out the
delta, the sensitivity of R&D spend per
share to EPS, if R&D spend went to zero at
both Shopify and Overstock.
So we work out a ratio for Shopify, for
example, $4.84 per share of R&D spend.
And they had $3.98 of earnings per share
in 2020, EPS zero.
So we divide $4.84 by $3.98, and we get a
ratio of 1.22.
Which means if Shopify decreased its R&D
spend to zero, we see a potential increase
of 122% in EPS.
It's a delta of 122%, so a potential 122%
increase in earnings per share.
With Overstock, we take the R&D spend of
$3.34 per share, and we divide by the
earnings per share of $1.24 in 2020, EPS
zero.
And we get a ratio of 2.69 times, which
means there could be a potential increase
of 269% in earnings per share if Overstock
pared down its R&D to zero.
Now, obviously, with our workings, this is
all very approximate and back of the
envelope.
And also, we've made the assumption that
companies like Shopify and Overstock can
actually pared down their R&D to zero and
live without R&D spent.
Which is obviously an assumption that
we're making here, but that's okay.
What you've witnessed here is a process
whereby all we did was start with the
table on the screen, the downloadable data
where we had our PE numbers.
We had our EPS numbers, we had our EPS
numbers, and our PEG numbers.
And what you've witnessed is a process
where we are investigating through lines
of inquiry after we have downloaded that
data.
And then we've asked the obvious questions
and followed lines of inquiry that have
enabled us to find out what is going on
with these stocks and what is going on
generally in the sector.
So, we download the data, we organize our
table, we get the statistics that are the
most important statistics for us.
We get market cap, we get price earnings
ratio, we get EPS earnings growth and PEG
ratio.
And then first step, we organize by PE1,
so forward-looking PE, and we find out
what the market likes and what the market
dislikes.
That's our first step.
Our next step was to filter by earnings
growth 1 and then earnings growth 2 to
figure out if the market is rewarding
companies or punishing them for their
earnings growth.
And then after ranking some stocks by
earnings growth 1 and 2, we start to
figure out and dig a little deeper that
there's companies that are being rewarded
for not just earnings growth, but revenue
growth.
So, we start to figure out now that
there's stocks in this particular sector
that are revenue growth stories and the
market is rewarding that revenue growth.
What we also realized through our lines of
inquiry as we dig a little deeper into the
numbers is that companies of different
market cap sizes are at various stages of
the growth and maturity phase.
So, Shopify is essentially maturing, it's
getting to the maturity level now.
Now, Wayfair has essentially matured, it's
almost maturing, getting into profit and
with lower revenue growth.
And over stock is still in the growth
phase.
So, over stock was the only one of our
stocks where the post-Covid 2022 revenue
growth forecast was higher than pre-Covid
levels.
So, revenue growth is still in the growth
phase.
The company is moving from a loss-making
position to a position of profit forecast
by the market and they have the highest
delta of R&D spend per share to earnings
per share.
Therefore, from a service level,
quantitative perspective and from a
traders and volatility perspective, over
stock potentially has the most upside.
But remember guys, this is not a trade
idea yet.
This is simply an example of the processes
that we go through at the beginning when
we pull up the table, we organize our data
in the spreadsheet, we interpret the
numbers and we initiate lines of inquiry.
And we start to figure out what's going on
with positive and negative outliers in a
sector.
So, we start digging, we interpret the
numbers properly, we start digging and we
start looking for it in this example at
potential positive outliers that could
become trade ideas and positions in the
future.
It's an identification process.
And what we've done here is potentially
identified over stock as a potential trade
idea.
And of course, there must be further work
done on this.
This is just the beginning.
So, we're going to look at the market.
So, the market is rewarding companies like
Shop for their revenue growth.
So, the natural move here is to actually
look at a metric of a revenue multiple
instead of an earnings multiple like price
earnings.
So, the way to work this out is to
actually take a company's market cap and
divide it by revenue.
So, when we look at our three stocks,
Shopify, $141 billion market
capitalization.
If we look at their 2021 forecasted
revenue by the market, which is $4
billion, we get to approximately 35 times
revenue.
With Overstock, we get 1.1 times revenue
or 1.17 times revenue.
And Wayfair, we get to 2 times revenue.
So, something is going on here with Shop.
We need to obviously ask our questions,
our obvious questions.
Why is the market paying 35 times for $4
billion forward revenue at Shopify and
only 1.17 times revenue for 2.65 billion
forward revenue at Overstock?
And only 2.09 times for $15.8 billion for
$15.8 billion of forward revenue at
Wayfair?
We go back to our default interpretation.
Is the market wrong?
What does the market know that I don't?
Well, the market obviously isn't wrong.
So, at this stage with our lines of
inquiry, we have to assume that
something's going on here, that the market
knows something that I don't.
It could be because of additional
quantitative metrics or even qualitative
factors.
Certainly, the revenue growth numbers in
the 30s in terms of percentage growth
numbers is much higher than the forecasts
for Overstock and Wayfair.
So, for Shopify, if you recall, 2021
revenue growth on 2020 was 37% and 2022
revenue growth from 2021 was 31%.
So, yes, the revenue growth numbers are
forecasted to be higher, but it could also
be because of other quantitative and
qualitative factors.
It's obviously a huge difference in
revenue multiple when you look at Shopify
versus Overstock and Wayfair.
So, it obviously might be worth continuing
at this stage to investigate why Shopify
has such a high revenue multiple and also
price earnings multiple in order to see
what the market rewards in the sector.
So, it's probably worth finding out the
reason why this is happening.
And just to give you a clue, it's not just
about the revenue growth number, okay?
It's also about how they make their
revenue.
So, check in the financial statements that
we looked at earlier for sales and
services revenue and what they've called
other revenue and compare this to Wayfair
and Overstock.
And then you can do further investigation
on that.
But as mentioned previously with Shopify,
it doesn't fall into the traders remit of
the volatility and 20 to 60 day time
horizon because of the size of the company
and the company reaching maturity.
So, you would still do further work on it
to get the context of what the market is
rewarding in the sector and why.
But we would be looking more towards
stocks and companies like Overstock as
traders and portfolio managers for trade
ideas.
So, what we have shown you here is the
process.
It's the process that you go through when
analyzing the most important fundamental
data in a sector when you're trying to
identify potential long ideas.
We systematically went through price
earnings ratio, earnings growth, market
capitalization, revenue growth and even
revenue multiples and started interpreting
the data and digging deeper to try and
find the answers.
What we are doing here and what we are
trying to do all the time, whether it's a
long or a short idea, we are looking for
fundamental tailwinds, directional
tailwinds.
The answer we want here is a yes or a no
as to whether Overstock is a fundamental
buy at this moment in time.
Now, of course, things will change in the
future and Overstock is an example.
Please don't be the dummy that comes up
with this idea and just copy trades it and
or hindsight the work that's been done.
We are showing you the process here.
It's not yet an idea or even a trade at
this stage.
Please focus on the process.
The exercises we went through, for
example, with R&D spend apply in this
sector because it's obviously important
for this sector.
How do we know this?
Well, through our lines of inquiry after
interpretation because the valuations are
telling us that it's not just about the
level of earnings for a stock in this
sector.
We realize that we have to look at revenue
growth and the progression to maturity of
a company.
However, regardless, the process that we
went through identified the fundamentals
that we have to focus on for this
particular sector.
If we didn't engage in the process, if we
didn't engage in the process, if we didn't
ask the obvious questions and keep
digging, we would never know.
So, this is why sticking to the process is
so important, guys.
The process itself is what you need to
focus on because it's applicable to every
single sector and it's a repeatable
process.
That's why we use it because repeatable
processes lead to generating a large
amount of high quality trade ideas, which
leads to consistent returns.
So, a robust and repeatable process is
required.
So, you must focus on the process.
So, now we always get this question at
ITPM from retail traders starting out.
So, beginners, when you first experience
earnings growth, people always ask the
question, what is a good or bad level of
earnings growth?
Well, let's start with this.
Just because a company has negative EPS,
for example, so it loses money, it doesn't
mean it's a short.
You've just witnessed that here when we've
looked at this sector.
Companies like Shopify or Overstock, they
lost money for years at the earnings per
share level because it was part of their
management operating plan.
They were growing the top line
intentionally by plowing revenue out of
R&D spent.
When you go through your process, you will
have to interpret data and figure out what
is good and bad to identify both positive
and negative outliers.
And part of this process, as you've
witnessed today, is the process of
filtering for earnings growth.
So, the natural question, and obviously we
don't blame people for asking this
question, the obvious question is what is
a good and bad level of earnings growth?
Well, this can be measured on both a
relative and absolute basis.
When you pull up a sector and you have all
of the data in front of you in the tables,
you can obviously sum up the column for
earnings growth and work out the mean
average consensus earnings growth for a
particular sector by just dividing by the
number of stocks in the sector.
And you will then be able to visually or
optically see the positive and negative
outliers very easily.
However, this does cut with a caveat.
Absolute earnings growth also matters.
If you find that the average for a sector
is negative, for example, and the most
positive outlier has earnings growth of,
say, 5%.
Why in the hell, as traders, would we want
to be longer stock that barely has
earnings growth above the rate of
inflation?
As traders, we simply don't.
We want to be long great stocks that go up
and short bad stocks that go down within
our 20 to 60 day time horizon.
There are obviously better longs out there
than stocks with crappy low 5% earnings
growth.
Remember, money likes growth and dislikes
slow downs in growth and even worse,
contraction.
So, guys, this brings us to the end of
this stage of the trade idea generation
process.
Let's go back to the desk for a quick
recap.
Okay, so welcome back to the desk.
Surprise, surprise.
Money likes growth.
So we start, guys, with our P ratio, price
earnings ratio.
That is our first clue when we're looking
at stocks to what the market likes or
dislikes.
So we start with price earnings ratio and
we work backwards price earnings ratio.
Then we move on to earnings growth and
revenue growth.
Always remember, guys, always remember
this.
There is always a reason why a stock
trades on a premium or a discount to its
sector peers.
There is always a reason.
And nine times out of 10 or even more than
that throughout stock market history, it
will be because the stock itself has
superior or inferior earnings growth and
or revenue growth.
So something will be driving that growth.
There's always something behind it.
So there's always a reason why it's
happening.
And there will be something behind it
driving it.
There'll be something that the market just
likes or dislikes about the stock.
Hence the premium valuation or the
discount valuation.
So we're going to look at fundamental
drivers later on in the video series.
But for now, we continue with the
quantitative processing steps.
So we identify what the market likes and
dislikes with price earnings ratio.
We then move to earnings growth and
revenue growth.
And then we move on to peg ratio.
So as we move through the quantitative
phase, utilizing our processes with
obviously correct interpretation.
What are we actually doing here?
We are building up a picture of the sector
and identifying the positive and negative
outliers.
And we're looking obviously in the end for
our potential long and short trade ideas.
So guys, let's continue with the
quantitative processing steps.
And let's move on and look in the next
video at peg ratio.